In Power BI, there are data types and there are data formats.
Data types impact the way that Power BI allows
the data to be used within Power BI reports and calculations.
Guessing data types is one of the ways that Power BI will try to help.
But often it'll guess wrong,
and you'll want to review this before you are trying to make a visual,
and I can't figure out why the value of sum or why
your DAX calculation has time intelligence that isn't working.
Data formats in comparison impact the appearance of
data for presentation and for reporting purposes.
This can be an important way to make your analysis user friendly and easy to read,
but it's not going to change the way the calculations themselves will work.
Let's start by discussing the three most common datatype categories.
Date/time data categories are the kind of things that include date, time,
or combinations of the two,
and they facilitate time intelligence such as DAX calculations like year to date.
Date tables also need
at least one date type date column to be able to explicitly be marked as a date table,
and for your data model that's going to be imported,
not only for ensuring that time intelligence is working correctly,
but also to make sure that the data is working
the way that you need it to for the purposes of your visualizations.
Texts strings are what you use generally
when we're dealing with a description of individual transactions,
or when you're dealing with groupings that are words rather than numbers.
Then the number types have three different flavors with subtly different purposes,
which we'll discuss next.
With number types, you want to choose wisely because they have subtly different purposes.
You want to use whole numbers when
your source information contains no decimals or fractions.
But note that this does not mean that the calculation like
an average of that field will still be reflected using only whole numbers.
There's also a very specific use case around
managing intermediary rounding in calculations that's a bit beyond our scope.
But I'll include a link where you can learn more.
Use fixed decimals when you need any rounding to be predictable and precise.
Note that this is not the same as when you update
the number format in Power BI's reporting layer.
The fixed decimal type will limit the rounding for calculations,
where reducing the number of decimals in
the formatting will only shrink the number shown for presentation,
and that'll be irrespective of what may have been used in the intermediary steps.
Currencies are the primary use for fixed decimals.
If you don't want to see a pending rounding error for a financial report, for example,
you want to fix decimal type,
and you want to ensure that everyone's rounding to the same number of decimals.
Finally, in most other instances,
you will be using a decimal.
This is by far the most common number type.
There are a few additional data types that are less common but handy.
These are true/false, which is basically a Boolean,
it's either one or the other.
Binary, which is really a temporary special datatype used just in the Query Editor.
It doesn't really play nice with data models,
and if you're loading binary files,
this is the preliminary data type that you'll use to load your data into Power Query,
which you should then adjust or remove,
depending on what your needs are.
If you choose to keep this column,
you're going to want to change its type.
Finally, percentage is actually a decimal value masquerading as its own type,
but I have to say it's awfully handy to be able to see a percentage
sometimes in the Power Query Editor when you're reviewing the data for accuracy.
There's no harm in using it in the Power Query Editor if it helps you with validation.